[Music]
excuse me good morning everyone
just came from the uh beautiful
excuse me
beautiful service we had never forget
tomorrow as you know is 9 11 can you
believe it's 19 years
since uh that terrible tragedy without
our country
this morning at 1003 uh we had
a remembrance for those who died
in the plane crash my plane
crashed in shanksville pennsylvania
actually the date is tomorrow
but so many people want to be on site on
the day of
uh so we had a a few of us there
at the invitation of the flight
attendants where they read the list
of people who had died
on all of the flights at 8 46
american airlines flight 11 at 903
united airlines flight 175
first was the world the north tower
second the south
tower 937
the pentagon american
airlines flight 77 into the pentagon
1003 united airlines
crashes into a field in shanksville
pennsylvania
that crash is memorialized right off the
rotunda of the capital
with the testimonial that
the courage of those people was so
remarkable
and that most likely the destination of
that flight
was the us capital but if you
have a moment in the next few days
the flowers the tributes are all there
and tomorrow morning
we'll be on the steps of the capitol of
course
at 8 46
never forget never forget never forget
the tragedy it was of course to our
nation that blow but never forget what
it meant to each and every family
to lose a loved one we are they're in
our prayers forever
and in our hearts as well again tomorrow
we'll be on the steps of the capitol at
the same time
uh it's a moment a terrible moment for
us in california
uh over three excuse me over two million
acres are burning possibly three million
homes
uh are uh evacuated thousands of homes
destroyed millions
more in the path of the blaze uh
wildfire ash is black
blanketing all the areas beyond the the
where the fire is in the bay area
turning the skies to orange
i've been getting calls from my family
and from uh
constituents about it's dark
it's it's dark there it's in the morning
they're waiting for the sun to come up
and it's dark all day they need
lights to drive with their headlights on
our thoughts and prayers of course are
with our firefighters who are so
courageous
we've already lost one in this fight and
we also lost a one-year-old boy among
the 15
dead in these fires just
the same time as we're having these
horrible fires
in california when i left over the
weekend to come back here for work
they um the
guidance were that the conditions were
unhealthy
smoky and unhealthy smoky and healthy
and now it's even
gotten worse than that i salute our
mayor
mayor breed and our governor
governor gavin newsom as they fight the
covet virus
to fight fighting these forest fires and
all that goes with that
very sad time but again our heroes
honoring our heroes of 9 11 honoring our
heroes these firefighters
fighting these fights it's uh is
humbling
at the same time as foreign i had a
really
uh sad conversation with the governor of
louisiana
uh last week he said he was talking
about the
hurricane that hit there the strongest
hurricane in the history of louisiana
the fifth strongest to ever hit the
united states in any location
i mentioned these in the same content
context because
climate change the climate crisis is
directly
related to both of them and this weekend
i have the honor
of hosting a g7 the g7
as you probably know every year that uh
the
g7 heads of state meet
about a week a month or two after that
the heads of parliament meet
of course this year the actual events uh
have been prevented from happening i
don't know
when president uh trump is going to
resume uh the the plans for a g7
meeting but we have our g7 heads of
parliament and that will be this weekend
i'm very proud of the participation
it'll be the all of the speakers
there's some are called presidents of
parliament uh of the g7 nations as well
as the
president of the european union we'll
all be together virtually
our
heroes committed to protecting the
environment in our planet will
be participating will be welcomed by
his holiness the dalai lama opening one
of our
sessions bono another
my one of my personal heroes jane
goodall will be participating
and the person who's called the father
of environmental justice
dr robert bullard from southern texas
university
will be one of our all-stars but we have
well you have the
rather than my reading of names you
should have our
press release on that two secretaries of
state secretary kerry secretary
albright one secretary of energy uh a
brilliant list that goes on and on uh to
discuss with the
speakers what our theme is uh when we
transferred from france the last
meeting wasn't most recent meeting was
in france
one year ago and then it was passed on
to me to be the
host for this year we announced last
year our theme would be
addressing the climate crisis
for economic and environmental justice
and that's what we our theme will be of
course
uh justice also is involved in how the
covet
virus is spreading so uh
we will focus on the climate crisis and
the covets
crisis and the economic and
environmental
justice involved in both so i'm very
very proud of that
it will be streamed you have the
information as to how to participate
so there we are now speaking of covet
i want to share some numbers with you
eight senior fda career executives
declared to usa today this is the heads
of their
centers we're following the science to
protect public health
in the pandemic look to usa today to see
their fuller statement
very important statement these are
serious scientists
and as as we have all said if the
science we want the science to dominate
the timing
of a vaccine we don't want it one day
later than it is ready
no one day sooner and we have to depend
on the science
and not the politics of the timing
a couple days ago that's eight a couple
days ago
nine pharmaceutical companies of the
heads released an extraordinary
joint statement that they would not put
forward a vaccine until it had been
thoroughly vetted for safety and
efficacy
that means going through the fda process
of of approvals
these are the companies that are doing
research on the vaccines
we hope and pray for vaccine then as
soon as it is ready
safe and efficacious and then
uh this week as well 11 so we have eight
senior fda saying we're following the
science
nine pharmaceutical companies we're not
going forward unless it's scientifically
approved
eleven directors of institutes at the
national institutes of health
stated that testing as many people as
possible
is the key to slowing down the spread of
the virus
testing testing testing we've been
singing that song for a long time and we
do have it
in the heroes act in a very robust way
i'm very proud strategic plan uh that
the
energy and commerce committee and the
leadership of chairman frank pallone put
forth based on science 75 billion
dollars
for testing tracing treating
sanitation separation mask wearing
and the rest to crush the virus
instead the administration has chosen to
crush the affordable care act
in front of the supreme court
pre-existing condition
benefit and all
but we have a very strong strategic plan
it's been there
in the works since may 15th but even
before that
our very first bill march 4th
was testing testing testing
scientists tell us we need to test up to
3 million people a day
in order to stop the spread of the
vaccine test
trace tree we're well
well well behind all of that
in the negotiation the uh and in the
mcconnell bill
they've said you want 75 billion we want
15 billion
we'll compromise at 16 billion
oh really oh really let's not have
tokenism
when we have a major
disaster let's not have a skinny bill
when we have a massive problem
i asked mr mr um colognes to chairman as
mr chairman
how how much flexibility do we have our
estimates on a regular basis
we need every penny in order to stop
this
and that's the way we're going to open
up our economy
and that's the way we're going to open
up our schools safely
is by crushing the virus
i don't even go into what happened
yesterday the fact that the president
knew he'd been saying for a long time
the whole thing was a hoax
his delayed denial and distortion of
what was happening has
caused many deaths even since
may 15th when we passed our bill
and mitch mcconnell pushed the pause
button
five million more people have that have
become infected
and over a hundred thousand people have
died columbia university
put out statistics months ago about how
many people would still be alive
if the if the uh science was followed
if the science had been followed so this
is a tragedy
beyond words what the president did
showed
yes in those comments showed his
contempt
contempt for the american people and
their health
contempt for science connect
contempt for any real effort to crush
the virus contempt for his supporters
their children their parents
he hid the facts and refused to take the
threat seriously
leaving the entire country exposed and
unprepared
he didn't want to cause a panic away
because of the stock market
nobody wants to cause a panic you want
to show leadership
show a strategic plan following the
science
allocating the resources in order to get
the job done
even now he refuses to listen uh to
science which is
just a tragedy and again uh the
republican mcconnell bill
is pathetically as chuck schumer
and i called it it's not only a skinny
bill it's emaciated it doesn't help
state and local workers
at all our heroes hence the name heroes
act healthcare workers first responders
police and fire
transportation sanitation teachers
teachers teachers food workers
who meet the needs of people will be
fired they risk their lives to save
lives
and now they may lose their jobs and you
know what they're going unemployment
insurance
so what are we saving harming
their lives and the need meeting not
meeting the needs of people
doesn't feed hungry families millions
millions maybe 14 million children are
food insecure in our country
our legislation makes a major commitment
to feeding the american people
renters major commitment to keep
people from being evicted and made
homeless
a plan that sprang from the what
happened when we had the
the great recession in 2008 9.
we had emergency assistance for renters
and we need to have it now president may
have a moratorium maybe so maybe not
but a moratorium without money is just
keeping debt
on these same people who may uh
evade eviction for the moment but are
not able to pay the rent and that causes
a problem
for the landlords as well of course they
don't want enough money
for us to for people to cast their
ballot safely we know that
and again let's just come right back to
the point
crush the virus have the resources
in order to do it
open your mind to what science is
proposing
so in any event as i mentioned we're
very pleased that the fda
career executives have come forward
about
trusting the science as we develop a
vaccine
the pharmaceutical company saying
they're not moving forward
unless it meets the standards
and are not and not my view that was an
important message because of the
apparent politicization of this of the
process by the oval
office and the directors at the national
institute of
testing testing testing
testing why would they not do that
there's so many other issues about us
going back to school i'm very proud
of my my members who um
who had participated in our day of
action on going back to school
a week or so before that they did the
day of action to protect the postal
service members and their constituents
although it's all virtual can't be
actual
uh are very engaged uh in in matters
that direct at
practically every household in our
country directly or indirectly certainly
the postal service and then the
education
of america's children important to each
and every one of us
any questions
yes sir i wanted to start go back to the
california wildfires and the wildfire in
the west
if joe biden and the democrats take
control of the government in november as
you've predicted
do you think that major climate change
legislation will be one of the first
pieces of legislation out of the gates
for the democrats in the new congress
well the uh we will have uh
what we have obviously hopefully the
covet
uh pandemic will have subsided if
there's
any thought that the republicans in
congress
will pay attention to science right now
they're in a place where they don't
believe in science
and they don't like governance so they
don't want any reason to have to govern
to call for standards uh to defeat the
virus but
uh the virus of course has to in order
to open up our schools in our
and our um economy uh
has to be first and foremost but yes it
will be
an early part of the agenda as you
probably know or maybe you don't uh
when i was first speaker a number of
years ago climate
the climate crisis was my flagship issue
president bush was president together we
passed the most
significant energy bill in the history
of our country the equivalent of taking
millions
of cars off the road uh by raising the
emissions standards and
other provisions there we came together
he wanted nuclear i wanted renewables we
came together
the um then this time and
and we had a select committee on the
climate crisis this time i do again
under the leadership of kathy castor
they have put forth their report which
has received so many accolades from
scientific judges
of such reports that it is
objective strong and the formula that we
need to go forward
some of it is already in our moving
forward legislation
that we passed in the end of june
beginning of july a number of weeks ago
and
the end of june and uh that will be
obviously
i wish that the pres the president says
he's for infrastructure we could
pass a bill having some of those green
uh
resilient we call it resilient because
green is a word that scary to some
people around here
so when joe biden says
build back better that better includes
building back in a way that is resilient
that is green that protects the planet
so what will be a part i don't know if
it's one bill or
it permeates a number of bills but it is
absolutely a priority and our priorities
uh
uh the um one of our
our climate action now legislation that
we passed
is going to be early legislation for us
to have to
return to the paris accords but to
better do better
to do better than that this is a
priority this is a challenge
you know a pandemic
descends upon you and eclipses
everything
preserving the planet for future
generations
is the challenge to this generation
we are late america is not a leader
in this under republican presidents
president obama did a great job in paris
with the paris accords
of course president trump defying
science
contempt for science walked away from
that
but this is a very big issue it's a
health issue
clean air clean water it's a jobs issue
green technologies to
keep america preeminent and make america
even more preeminent in the world
and promoting green technologies it's a
national security
issue national security experts whether
they're in the military in the
diplomatic corn the scientific core
whatever
have said to us this is a security issue
the rising sea levels the encroachment
of deserts
though drying up of the great rivers
especially
uh in asia so many
of the consequences of the climate
crisis the melting
of the polar cap so many
of the aspects of the climate crisis
eat away at habitat and resources
and can cause conflict
even in terms of migration issues i was
in central america
on the immigration issue
within the last year and we were trying
to say why
what is it that we can do to keep people
at home what about the economy and the
rest
and one of the things that was so
evident
in central america was the drought had
prevented farmers from farming
hence seeking other opportunity
so it has an impact on migration on
security on health
on jobs it's also a moral issue if you
believe as do i that this
planet is god's creation and we have a
moral obligation to be good stewards of
it
then it's a moral obligation if you
don't share that religious view
but you do understand that we have an
obligation to
handing the planet over to our children
and grandchildren in a responsible way
uh then we all can agree on that
and so that's why i'm so excited about
what we're doing this weekend with the
g7
uh again focusing on addressing the
climate crisis
addressing economic and environmental
justice
as we do so yes sir what's your outlook
for getting a stimulus deal at this
point yesterday mr schumer said for some
indication venusian might move off of
this one trillion dollar line
do you share that kind of optimism and
then part two on the cr are you pushing
for a cr into next year or until later
we are two questions let me start with a
crm
i have said publicly that i'm for clean
cr mr mnuchin
mr secretary has said he's brought clean
cr uh so we're down the
we're down that path we are now looking
at anomalies and the rest and we'll
figure out the timing when we do in
terms of the
i'm optimistic that uh that the
the need for state and local government
to be uh
uh met the needs must be met and that
will
i think insists that the number be
bigger than what the republicans are
talking about now
the fiscal stability of state and local
government
is very important to the fiscal
stability
of our country the economic security of
our country
so to say well let them get fired and go
on unemployment
and cut the needs of them meeting the
needs of people and
raising taxes i don't think that sounds
like
a very popular or effective more
importantly
approach to it so i do i do hope
the most important
element of all of it is to stop the
virus
and maybe this expose or whatever you
want to call it
who didn't know what the president's
attitude was but nonetheless
this reinforcement of it uh will um
insist because i'm going to tell you
something about this
the disparity my talk about
our weekend of economic environmental
justice and when we talk about covid
there's covet injustice as well the
disparity among
populations of color people of color
is shameful that we have not done the
outreach
that we have not done the testing
tracing treatment in a way
that has would
stop the spread and save the lives
um i'm wondering can we get your view on
brexit there's been developments
this week in london and the british
government has introduced new
legislation that
appears to be overriding some of its
commitments to the eu i know you put out
a statement last night but we just
wondered could i get your
views on that well thank you for that
question
uh over one year ago through the 21st
anniversary
of the good friday accords
i took a delegation we went to uh
we went we visited our troops we always
on a bus
on a uh codel it's always about security
and it's about economy and then we went
to the uk
where i met with all elements whether it
was the government
or the members of the government's party
who were opposed
to the government position of leaving
the eu
i met with the
labor party and those who are opposed to
the labor party's
positions on a number of things there
are four elements
to make sure they all understood
in the uk don't mess with the good
friday accords this is something that
as americans we're very proud of our
participation in
recognition of nobel status given
to what happened there president clinton
being so much a part of it george
mitchell and others on both sides of the
of of the atlantic and within uh the
movement in um
in northern and in this in ireland
i then went to we went then went to
dublin and i spoke to the doyle that
is the parliament of ireland i had a
beautiful invitation
to speak to their parliament and i said
to them
that we still that the good friday
accords
were very high priority for us democrats
and republicans house and senate
so that if the uk
did anything to undermine the good
friday accords
they should not as i told them in the uk
four different elements of participation
there
they should not even think about having
a u.s
uk bilateral trade
agreement the british and the irish work
together
they came to terms it was part of the
international
treaty uh going forward with the
departure of the brits
from the eu and then
this news comes to us practically in the
middle of the night
uh over the weekend monday
later in the day there early in the
morning here that the uk had decided
uh to undermine the good friday accords
what were they thinking whatever it is
i hope they're not thinking of a uk u.s
bilateral trade agreement to make up for
what they might lose
and losing the it's up to the people of
the uk
for them to decide if they want to
belong to the eu and the rest
that's their judgment that's their
decision that's to be respected
but don't think you're going to get a
reward if you undermine
now i've been to ireland many times i
have a son-in-law whose family
lives there so we have funerals we have
baptisms we have
a lot going on in ireland and on
one of those occasions i i took the
train
from dublin to belfast to meet up with a
codel that was up there following one of
our christenings
and at that time
tanks and guns and soldiers and at the
border was
frightening frightening
when we went for the 21st anniversary
the only way you could tell you were in
ireland or northern ireland was the
color of the stripe
on the ground the free flow of goods the
free flow of people the commerce the
rest of it
and they hosted us and the uk and
belfast the
speaker there hosted us with a um
a big i would guess reception but it was
more like a rally
of children and two of them spoke
a protestant and a catholic seniors in
high school
saying they lived their whole lives in
peace
and they weren't going back these good
friday accords
were just so beautiful and we are not
going to have them tampered with
or reward any messing with them
uh with a bilateral uk u.s trade
agreement
johnson speaker have you spoken to boris
johnson the prime minister
no no not since the other day but i will
be speaking to the ambassador
i believe the foreign minister they're
coming another few days
our members now understand this i'm
speaking for
our chair of is a bipartisan way we've
always gone there in a bipartisan way
richie neil is the president the head
the co-chair
of the fred's of ireland he's also the
chair
of the ways and means committee which is
the committee of jurisdiction
of trade agreements uh he has been
speaking to the press you probably have
heard his statements bbc and the rest
as have any number of our members this
my phone was ring off the hook it's been
ringing off the hook because of
what's happening in california and all
of a sudden it was
the uk is abandoning what it said it
would do
on um the good friday accords
thank you for your questions for london
um what's your message to london to make
clear to the johnson government
it cannot jeopardize peace in ireland
something which i know you've fought so
passionately for over a number of years
well our message is very clear
self-determination is what the uk the
people of the uk
have determined their course of action
that's
up to them but it is up
not up to them to think that they will
be rewarded
if they mess with the good friday
accords and think that they're going to
be rewarded
it's it's it's really sad actually
because when they had the agreement with
the
the previous prime minister shock now
it's a new jitter but
the previous t-shock um it was
really good news they trusted that was
it was really good news and that really
that very same night
the irish from all over were honoring
richie neal
and so we had a double celebration that
okay this is going to be okay this is
going to be okay
but it's a very simple message they know
it
they've heard it i've said it to the
doyle this is not anything with hidden
under a bush
there will be no bilateral u.s u.k
agreement if the border the good friday
accords
in regard to the border
are changed and actually
how can they walk away from an
international agreement how do you trust
that we've made an international
agreement
this is how we'll go forward oh never
mind
oh never mind but anyway again their
self-determination is
up to them our trade relations are up to
us
madam speaker madam speaker thank you
[Laughter]
but you put your hand up right in front
of her face but okay
in any event can you give us some
clarity from your perspective
as to what a clean cr is you know
sometimes that's in the eye of the
beholder
and that could be that could predicate
how long this runs if it runs to next
year if you have a
democratic senator or a president biden
which you might prefer to do business
with obviously
but also if they came and said okay
here's a little bit of coronavirus
relief
no that's not true that's not going to
be there no
they one of the things uh
continuing resolutions 101 uh continuing
resolution is a resolution that
continues
uh the the appropriations process
and the same outlays as the previous
year
we did very well last year in the
negotiations
so to be able to continue at that rate
of pay shall we say
okay now there are some what we call
anomalies some things that expire this
or that
that may or may not be continued but
still are
technically within the definition of
clean
clean meaning no additional things covet
would be clean
would not meet that definition and those
negotiations
are separate from this and you think if
you don't get something obviously we're
gonna have this procedural vote in the
senate this afternoon
it's probably not going to get anywhere
here but that probably puts
an end to any effort to do coronavirus
until after the election
no why no no no i think that uh
i think that mcconnell was
bringing his cynical self by saying i'll
just put something on there
it'll look like we're trying to do
something while we ignore the needs of
the american people
where we shy away from defeating and
crushing the virus
uh while we say to people at their
kitchen tables uh
we don't care if you don't have food or
if you're out on the street in another
month than the rest of that
but just have to say i put something
there check the box
check the box push the button
pause i forgot to tell the virus to
pause
a half a million no
five million more people infected
since he pushed the pause button a
hundred
thousand or more dead since he pushed
the
pause button so this is sort of a as
chuck calls it the emaciated
uh and as he also said this morning i
thought
trump lied people died we're in a very
sad situation here
and this is a big fight uh because it's
about the role
of government to protect the american
people
and that protection includes respect for
science
science to stop the spread science and
not
politics to determine how a vaccine
will be for be developed and how
ethically it will be distributed
to people in our country we pray
for vaccine we hope it will be soon
not one day sooner than it is safe and
efficacious
safety and efficacy are the standard
approved by the scientists at the fda
approved by
independent advisory group
objectively measuring whether it should
go forward
and with an ethical plan to distribute
it
to people in our country so that
everyone has access to it
so it is a you know
it's a big challenge and you should
really start
by respecting science thank you all very
much
thank you so tomorrow perhaps we'll see
you on the steps of the capitol
thank you thank you